24 tonnes de terre et de graminées
sauvages ont envahi la maréchalerie de
versailles une sculpture vivante
intitulé lacunes féconde réalisée par
l'artiste plasticien et architecte de
marc johnson diplômé des beaux-arts de
paris et de l'école nationale supérieure
d'architecturé de paris malaquais
l'artiste propose une approche à la fois
sensible et abstraite des enjeux
bioéthiques
ici on est dans une problématique qui
ouvre à une certaine transversalité des
disciplines c'est un artiste qui
croisent dans ce projet en particulier
l'armée aussi l'archéologie la génétique
c'est cela aussi qui était intéressant
et singulier de sa part c'était de
tenter de créer à travers le dispositif
dans lequel on circule quitter ce
paysage donc végétalisée revégétaliser
où la nature reprend ses droits
c'était vraiment de traiter de ces
questions transversales l'oeuvre vivante
vient confronté l'art ancestral de
l'archéologie au progrès scientifique
pour l'artiste les principales
évolutions du 21e siècle en
nanotechnologies biotechnologies
sciences du cerveau et intelligence
artificielle vient de transformer demain
l'industrie la médecine et les
neurosciences
une intelligence artificielle
accompagnent d'ailleurs le visiteur dans
le dispositif en déclamant un texte
autour de l'avenir de l'activité humaine
il ya un an de travail avec institut
national de recherches archéologiques
préventives
il s'agit de comprendre comment les
technologies aujourd'hui notamment
l'apport de la génétique en archéologie
va pouvoir transformer le vivant et pose
des questions fondamentales pour nous
aujourd'hui comme l'interaction des
technologies et notre corps propre les
neurosciences et donc des questions
philosophiques comme le mouvement
culturel
notamment le transit manis mme le
pressionnisme les études de marc johnson
sur le sujet ont amené à l'édition
prochaine d'un livre sur la bioéthique
et pour les visiteurs désireux de
s'approprier ce sujet un questionnaire
de vingt-et-une question est distribuée
pour prolonger la réflexion
philosophique et scientifique